[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
des questions au gouvernement de ce
mardi 31 mars 2020 une nouvelle fois
consacré exclusivement à la lutte contre
l'épidémie de coronavirus une séance
avec des règles très strictes
écoutez richard ferrand président de
l'assemblée nationale ne sont présents
qu'en nombre limité des ministres et un
seul député par groupe les questions
ayant le même thème sont regroupés comme
chaque question faisant l'objet d'une
réponse spécifique le nombre de
questions et réduits en revanche les
temps de parole sont les temps usuels
deux minutes par question et autant par
raiponce réplique ou contre eux réplique
éventuellement comprise première
question sur les tests de dépistage du
coc u19 le ministre de la santé olivier
verrons a promis une stratégie de
dépistage massif avec trente mille tests
par jour au moins d'avril mais à qui
vont bénéficier ces tests c'est le
député les républicains olivier marleix
qui pose la question vous annoncer que
vous des pistes auraient massivement
mais pour l'essentiel en sortie de
confinement c'est à dire que lorsque la
pandémie sera pour l'essentiel derrière
nous vous nous parlez d'un objectif de
100 mille tests par jour mais pour le
mois de juin ma question est très simple
qui va profiter de ce surcroît de tests
supplémentaires
êtes vous prêt à concentrer l'effort sur
les établissements pour personnes âgées
les personnes âgées sont les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles face à ce
virus et l'enfermement en chambre dans
les ehpad n'est pas une solution qui
pourra durer bien longtemps peu il ya
trois méthodes de test une méthode de
test dit par pcr qui est la méthode qui
est sûr que nous vous exerçons en france
comme dans le lancement des pays du
monde le font sur leur territoire une
technique qui est lourde qui passe par
des plateformes pcr des plateformes
technologiques
nous en avons acheté de nouvelles qui
sont répartis aux quatre coins du
territoire national dans les antilles
évidemment incluse comme l'épidémie
progresse qui est de plus en plus de
nouveaux malades et notamment des
soignants malades des personnes fragiles
malades des personnes hospitalisées
malades ou des personnes en ehpad ou des
gens qui travaillent en ehpad qui
peuvent être potentiellement malades ou
fragiles et et à protéger
l'augmentation de ce nombre de test
permet
de dépister systématiquement toutes ces
personnes ces publics prioritaires
au cours de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement une inquiétude majeure
autour des stocks de médicaments
utilisés pour les malades placés en
réanimation
c'est la présidente du groupe socialiste
et apparentés valérie rabault qui pose
la question au premier ministre pouvez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
oui ou non me confirmer que la france
dispose de stocks suffisants pour faire
fonctionner ces quatorze mille places de
réanimation et si oui sur quel horizon
de temps partout dans le monde
ça n'est pas propre à la france vous le
savez parfaitement partout dans le monde
la consommation des médicaments liés à
la réanimation est en train d'exploser
parce que le nombre de réanimation
explose littéralement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
mis en place un plan national qui
consiste à avoir des approvisionnements
nationaux de façon à pouvoir regrouper
les commandes et à pouvoir utiliser à la
fois la force de commandes groupées et
l'influencé de la diplomatie française
lorsque l'approvisionnement de ces
médicaments n'est pas strictement
nationale nous avons mis en place cette
méthode nous avons mis en place une
méthode qui vise à répartir ces fonds en
fonction des besoins dans les régions
pour veiller à ce que chacun puisse
avoir l'accès aux molécules nécessaires
c'est un exercice qui est un exercice
difficile nous avons pris des mesures
elles peuvent vous sembler elles peuvent
sembler accessoires ou aux minimes elles
sont en réalité très importante nous
avons par exemple fait en sorte qu'une
décision soit prise dans l'union
européenne pour que les médicaments
produits dans le territoire de l'union
européenne ou à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne puisse arriver sous une seule
forme d'emballage ça peut donner mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous c'est à dire
avec des emballages notamment écrit dans
une seule langue en anglais
nous l'avons fait parce que le simple
fait de permettre cette dérogation à une
règle qui normalement ne peut pas
prévaloir sur notre territoire national
a permis à certaines visites d'augmenter
par trois leur production de se
concentrer sur la production du produit
et pas sur les spécificités propres à
chaque pays le corona virus ferait il
ressurgir des inégalités sociales c'est
l'inquiétude de mathilde pas nos députés
la france au mythe du val de marne
les français sont respectueux des
consignes dans un moment de péril
sanitaire les inégalités elles ne sont
pas confinés 4 millions de pertes
ne sont mal logées 1,3 million vivent
dans des logements indignes
pour eux le confinement force et c'est
la prison nous avons prolongé le
bénéfice des minima sociaux sans
condition pour les bénéficiaires sur une
durée allongée de temps de voir venir la
fin d'épidémie afin que personne ne se
retrouve privé du rsa privé de la hache
privé de toutes les allocations sociales
vous dire également que nous avons
prolongé la trêve hivernale qui devait
s'arrêter le 31 mars au 31 mai ce qui
offre une protéine garanties de
protection pour des gens qui sont sans
abri par exemple ou qui sont dans des
hébergements précaires ou en difficulté
pour payer leur loyer vous dire
également que nous travaillons avec
julien de normandie d'arrache-pied à
toutes les solutions qui permettent
d'augmenter les hébergements d'urgence
destiné au public précaire trek arisée
qui sont dans la rue qu'il soit sdf
qu'il soit migrants ou qu'il n'est tout
simplement pas de domicile dessin pour
pouvoir vivre et passer cette crise dans
des conditions décentes et digne vous
dire que je travaille et que nous
travaillons en lien avec l'ensemble des
ong la croix rouge médecins du monde
médecins sans frontières et des
associations qui viennent en aide aux
publics fragiles aux personnes isolées
qui font preuve d'innovation dans la
solidarité dont personne ne doutait mais
qui se révèlent en plus redoutablement
efficace dans la période et que les
services de l'état les remercie et sont
allés à leurs côtés pour mener avec elle
ce combat qui je le dis n'a rien de
politique qui a tout du main autre
dossier clé la hausse des violences
conjugales et des violences contre les
enfants pendant le confinement
l'occasion d'une annonce du ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner
désormais les victimes pourront pas
celle alerte par simple sms
je souhaite vous annoncer que en lien
avec mes collègues du gouvernement nous
mettrons en place à partir de demain la
possibilité de donner l'alertent par
simple texto pour que le texto puisse
donner une alerte et qu'ensuite les
forces de sécurité intérieure
interviennent c'est une proposition
d'ailleurs construite avec laurent
wauquiez président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes qui m'a signalé la
disponibilité du 114 et de la plate
forme qui est gérée par des services
hospitaliers de grenoble et qui nous
permettra là aussi par le 114 de donner
l'alerté par simple texto parce que en
aucun cas le confinement de doit être
l'empêchement et le fait de laisser des
violences conjugales ou des violences
intrafamiliales
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement de ce mardi 31 mars 2020
une nouvelle fois vous l'avez vu
consacrer à la lutte contre l'épidémie
de coronavirus rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débrief